heyo jimmy and michael here and we both
became jedi in Disney's Star Wars Jedi
challenges here are on impression today
[Music]
so this is actually an experience and it
is AR but it is unlike Pokemon go or
even like apples AR kit while you're
using a phone you're actually gonna slot
it into this headset and it allows you
to see characters like Darth Maul and
things like that in front of you but at
the same time you can also see your
living room speaking of the Darth Maul
in our first experience we actually got
to fight against Darth Maul using a
lightsaber and Michael would you think
about that experiences all I know house
I walked on a man I thought the tracking
went really well I think that's the most
important thing for something like this
you do get that lightsaber attachment
that you mentioned earlier yeah you
press the button on your lightsaber the
thing lights up and then Darth Maul
comes at you so I thought like the setup
is really cool the tracking worked
really well when you're playing you know
the force will tell you where to block
his incoming attacks and you kind of got
to line up your lightsaber to match that
to make sure you survive and you got a
swing back at him I thought that was
really cool my only complaint with it it
was that I thought the the vertical
field of view was a little narrow it was
a little hard to keep track of what was
going on in that sense but overall in
terms of functionality I thought it
worked well yeah what's it the tracking
is good maybe not as good as like say
something like the HTC vive but I would
say it's like definitely adequate after
that we got to try out a game where we
deflected lasers from incoming droids
like that I thought that was a little
bit harder in the sense that your depth
perception is a little off it was hard
to tell when lasers were coming in
exactly what direction so you know when
I didn't have that problem so maybe just
gotta get good Michael sorry
yeah I'm tell that the dark la man I
thought it worked okay and like as the
incoming joints got closer because they
kind of start off far away you can like
slash out on and then I think later on
you can open up by force abilities and
things like that yeah and there's like a
hand icon so that you can actually kind
of push them away and you you do that it
doesn't track your hands so you actually
have to press a button on the lightsaber
to do it Michael you didn't actually
kind of follow that and it was so
immersive I guess though we like this
the force of force was within me man I
saw that and I knew I could push him
away but I guess not quite yet these are
initial impressions we only played like
first rounders I'm curious to see what
other elements they put on top of these
things building off of what we already
saw I think that's what's gonna sustain
this thing to be a little bit more than
just a gimmick and I think that the
pieces are there and then the second
sort of mode that we played was like a
strategy mode it was sort of like tower
defense /ig you can drop down like an
obi-wan I dropped down like heavier
class stormtroopers dropped down turrets
you know what do you think about that
I've seen this a lot in AR it's kind of
par for the course in terms of an AR
game-mode where it is like virtual tower
defense where you place down things in
the world and then you kind of interact
with the actual layout of where you are
and where it's set up and I don't think
there's that much to it at least from
what we saw just now but you know it's
it's part of a package that kind of
rounds out all the different things that
you can do and then they encourage you
to actually like get low to the ground
because I want to kind of simulate you
over seeing like a really tiny battle
and with like little action figures
moving across that's pretty cool and the
last one that we played was something
that you might have seen in the movies
it's the Star Wars kind of battle chess
kind of thing where we like you know
selected monsters and then have them
move forward and progress and attack the
other monsters across the table and what
you think about that experience yeah so
I imagine that that can get a little bit
more exciting than it initially was
things like maybe like a tactic style
yeah there's like a turn-based tactics
kind of thing sorry yeah and all in all
you know they're saying that you can get
roughly twelve hours of gameplay from
this which is in bed the headset does
cost two hundred dollars so it's most
likely gonna appeal to more enthusiasts
than casual Star Wars fans yeah but if
you're interested with gonna have some
potential they also change some you know
forthcoming games that are gonna support
the headset too so yeah keep your eyes
out on it
[Music]